hey I was gonna branches very late I'm
very tired I don't know if you can tell
on me can you know anyway I got the the
offer to play exclusive offer to play
insurgent on the oculus insurgent which
is which is a new movie coming out very
sci-fi a very VR II which fits perfect
with the oculus spin a while since we
played about it so I'm very excited to
check it out look light studious oh my
god let me put it on there we go
summit baby summit baby Titan lightning
baby Titan lightning baby what just
happened insurgent shatter reality oh my
god is being shouted right in front of
me I said it's this real-life I should
just make a day back to after dentist oh
my god what this is so weird what what
is going on what are you guys five is
ready no no I'm not ready don't look at
me like that
you're about to enter a series of mental
simulations but I don't want to say
shion's wisely what I'm terrible at
decision-making we'll start there
understanding your role in society is
important for the sake of humanity all
right we need to remove those who don't
fit that must not fail oh god no I'm not
ready I said I wasn't ready
ah oh what's happening oh dude it stinks
load on my nipper oh my oh my god Oh
what what
oh my god no I did not sign up YouTube
for this no oh Jesus Christ oh my god
that's awesome
what do you come from so another one of
my own turns out to be diverging so what
what was that freakin birds man
it's by the way one way to spy what is
that let's see no no no no no you're me
yeah damn it
kind of like this I don't stop stop
stupid Briggs I'm not scared are you
burnt flap don't poop in my face please
oh my god do I have to do something no
no I'm terrible at doing stuff god
frickin Birds man what am I supposed to
do
don't hurt me I'm a trekker Debra damn
it doesn't work are you kidding me did I
do it well call the real surprise to our
dauntless
after all thank you now let's see how
smart oh thanks pretty smart I would say
- all good don't do that don't do that
did not ask for this oh my god ah what
what oh my god
I'm scared I'm so scared uh how smart am
i that I did I pass the smartest tell
you what I'll help you out for old times
sake Thank You mallet you don't have
much time so the important thing here is
to focus on the challenge at hand
okay akkad sidetrack playing it's a
necessary distraction uh-huh like move
like that you dick what you drink mate
you think you got this figured out
uh yeah I gotta figure it out it's gonna
stop this train from plowing ah don't
worry this'll only hurt
ah ah my
I bet I look like a total tool playing
this but it's really awesome am i okay
my nips are fine I made it past the
second simulation oh the subject loose
Thanks
I want to study this one don't hey I'm
not a I'm not a pet
shatter reality insurgent baby
oh man ah I miss doing these awesome
oculus games cuz uh it's a lot of fun
it's really cool I wish you bros could
do it with me oh oh hey it's pills from
the future again I was wrong
you can check out the game for yourself
check out the link in the description
and have a have a go at it in case you
didn't realize the film is called
insurgent and it's come to theatres
March 20 that is all I must now got
return to peace but for now hope you
boys enjoy this video thank you boys for
watching you have beautiful faces they
look very soft and cuddly stay awesome